this question comes under the category
of applications of differentiation you
can see there's a lot of language in
here that's all physics language you've
got motion velocity acceleration all
that kind of thing so there's a lot of
language here that needs to be unpacked
which is one of the particular peculiar
things about this question and the other
thing that's unusual is that you get no
equations in this question handed to you
everything has to be interpreted and
answered visually it's all in basis of
this graph so if you think back to when
we're looking at graphing techniques
you're not actually asked to draw very
much in this question but all the stuff
that you knew about derivatives and also
the implications on what the shape of
the graph will look like I going to come
into play in this question so you won't
be able to interact with many of the
numbers at least not least not directly
so there is so much here so let's unpack
start by starting at the top question it
says a particles moving horizontally so
that it's displacement X meters to the
right of the origin at time T seconds is
given by the graph to the right and
that's the graph that you've got there
so immediately the first thing to notice
here which is kind of weeds you out and
has some implications for the way that
you answer the question is this particle
is moving horizontally let's just change
that it's a bit easier to see moving
horizontally and it's a displacement is
given by X except for the fact that and
this happens all the time in
displacement questions X is on the
vertical axis not the horizontal axis so
you can see it up there
so what it's saying is displacement is
measured to the right of the origin so
when you are moving and to get ready for
this it's weird when you are moving up
in terms of the graph the actual
particle is moving to the right so up
means to the right and by contrast if
you are moving down on the graph like so
because that means you're moving closer
to the origin from the right-hand side
you are actually moving left so all of
that is a little bit weird we're going
to come back to the implications of that
a bit later on but for now I just want
to signal that fact that this up-down
left-right business is something that
you need to be conscious of the units
are in time of the unit off time or in
seconds and then the units of display
meters so now I become important later
on we'll see how we go all right so the
first question says in the first 10
seconds
what is its maximum distance from the
origin and when does it occur so there's
two questions there right number one
what is its maximum distance so that's
going to be a displacement unit of some
kind and then the next question is when
does it occur so we're gonna have to
have a time that goes with this okay now
what I've got down here is a bigger
version of this same graph for us to
work with here you can see that I've got
my distance you can see it's it's saying
like when in the first ten seconds is
its maximum distance from the origin so
I have more than ten seconds worth of a
situation here this goes all the way
over to 12 and presumably further on but
I'm only interested in the first 10 so
what we'll do is we'll do a sort of
domain restriction I guess on the part
of the graph that we're interested in I
want 10 so I don't have a 10 on my axis
you so I'm gonna put 1 no I think I'm
okay with that so um this lines up to
here so this is kind of that spot right
there that's time 10 so this is sort of
effectively for this part of the
question anyway where my graph is going
to end and then I'm looking for greatest
distance from the origin now you can see
this particular function for
displacement um it never goes negative
which is to say that it never goes to
the left of the origin right I know this
starts to get very confusing so what I'm
gonna do here is I'll have another graph
here and this is going to become even
more useful later on as we start talking
about left-right more explicitly I'm
actually going to rotate this around so
that right is right and left is left so
obviously you can just take your page
and you can move it around but I can't
do that to my screen so hopefully this
shows you this convinces you right that
the axis which is now sitting vertically
is where the origin is okay so moving to
the right is a heading over in that
direction over there and you're never to
the left of the origin right so the
greatest distance is well how far to the
right do you go in that first 10 seconds
so coming back to our original graph you
can see in this section it's relevant
and
like so this is the first 10 seconds
here and then I stop so clearly it's the
highest point on this graph we would say
the global maximum within that domain
which I think we can clearly see we can
clearly identify is happening here so
that's that distance like what is the
distance it's 8 meters so I can start to
write some answers now the greatest
distance is 8 meters and because it's a
question of distance doesn't matter
whether it's to the left or the right so
I can say 8 meters is the maximum
distance and then the next thing they
ask is well when does that occur
so because it's a win question I'm going
to go down to the time axis and you can
see it goes all the way down from this
point down to time equals 3 so 8 minutes
is the max distance which occurs at or
after 3 seconds okay so there's party
not too dramatic let's come back to the
questions it says by examining the
gradient find when the particle is
stationary moving to the right moving to
the left so let's do the easy part first
which is stationary right now we call
you know stationary point stationary
points because of this idea that they
sort of represent like when the particle
stops and moving right so essentially
I'm just looking for stationary points I
also notice that Part B has stopped the
restriction in Part A about the first 10
seconds so I won't worry about that
anymore now just looking at the entire
graph ok so when is the particle
stationary well let's get rid of all of
our previous working here because it's
no longer relevant so I'm just gonna
clear that off I'm looking for
stationary points so I can see one here
which was actually the same spot I had
before that makes sense because we were
looking for a global maximum
it happened at a turning point which is
also a stationary point in this context
anyway and then you've got this other
stationary point down here at the bottom
so when is it stationary I've got two
places two times rather so I'm gonna say
Part B Part one particle is stationary
at three seconds and also at nine
seconds looking at where I've put that
other blue marker okay so there are the
stationary points that wasn't too
complicated but now we need to think
again about left right and what that
means for the gradient okay so you can
see here
let's what's answer the question first
of when it's moving to the right okay so
if we look at my left right graph over
here when is it moving to the right um
you can highlight these sections right
starting from time zero go back to this
color sometimes you're oh I'm literally
moving to the right as you can see over
here right you see what I did it so that
section in there it's moving to the
right and then if you have a look at
this other section that I'm gonna
highlight here this now I'm literally
moving back towards the left so I'm not
I'm not interested in that part of the
graph and then after that stationary
point which we already identified at
time nine it starts moving to the right
again okay so you can see it's literally
moving to the right moving to the right
so these are the sections I'm interested
in so when you come back to your
original graph that's to the left of
this stationary point and to the right
of this stationary points so I guess in
terms of thinking about the gradient I
can interpret positive gradient as
moving to the right so I'm really asking
the question and you can write this down
for yourself if you like but I'm asking
for when is the derivative it's not dy
its DX DX on DT when is a positive okay
in this scheme moving to the right means
the positive direction and it's worth
mentioning like I could have defined
this differently I could have said that
moving to the left was positive and it
just depends on what the situation is so
you must read carefully to say what is
it telling you it is conventional that
going to the right is positive but um it
could be anything you like that's kind
of the point of this you can define the
origin in the directions in whatever way
is convenient to you okay so now I know
DX 1 DT is greater than 0 when does that
occur and the answer is we start from
time zero so I'm actually going to say
you know for the first question I could
have said time equals three and
9 so here in terms of the inequality it
would be from time 0 and then I ended
three I can't say that it's moving to
the right at time 3 because we just said
in the previous part that you're
stationary at that point so so that's
that part there and then for the right
hand side it picks up at time 9 so time
is 9 and then you go all the way to the
right and there's no indication on the
graph that that ever stops so just the
one side of boundary so I would convert
that into words by saying particle is
moving right between 0 & 3 seconds and
after 9 seconds and you can see this is
just my my my verbal translation of all
the symbols that you can see up here
this is obviously much more concise but
the question is handed to us in words
right so therefore I'm going to use
words in my aunts on the final part in
this section anyway part 3 moving to the
left so this is well it's the part of
the graph that hasn't been highlighted
yet right so part 3
I'm looking for DX on DT being negative
so DX on DT is being negative in that
last section up above a highlight that
in red as well so that's this part here
on the right-hand graph you can see it's
literally moving over to the left over
there which corresponds to on the
original graph moving in the negative
direction so that's between 3 and 9 so I
will write that down both in terms of an
inequality that's between what do we say
3 & 9 and what that means is I wrote
translate into words particle is moving
left
between three and nine seconds and nine
seconds okay now I'm just going to pause
for a brief moment and who can move this
out of the way because I have other
working down here which is going to
become important later so I needed a new
page let's paste this back on my new
blank page all right that's better